that's
a hard shot back to valdez and he throws
it up the right field line
kemp's head to second so with one out
matt's in scoring position
fastball lined into center field for a
base hit
matt kemp rounds third he will score
rymel
tapio with an rbi shot up the middle
the rockies take a one to nothing lead
and that's a base hit the center field
chris owens
and tapia is going to press the issue
george springer said i'm not going to
bite on that
so the base is loaded now for drew
butera
the o2 that is grounded left side diving
for a he stops it
shovels the second for one altuve on the
first and it's in time to get a sliding
butter
excellent play by correa to his backhand
stopping it
and then a little shovel toss to altuve
at second base
inning over i'll bring up martine
maldonado
he put a good swing on it as does
martine maldonado deep to left field
machete with his third home run of the
year we're tied at one
there's some of that minute made park
magic heading to coors field
feels like forever since the astros have
hit a home run but that was a
laser beam out of this ballpark rockies
will send at the top of the order
against robert valdez
catcher sets inside here's the pitch
swing and a miss offered at a high one
beautiful breaking ball there's the
curveball that he picks up most of his
strikeouts in his career and he gets out
number two
here's bregman see what he has to say
about it he struck out his last time up
bregman will have something to show for
this slicing ball down the right field
line
alex is hobbling to second base not sure
what happened
but alex bregman slowly gets into second
base
looks good starts to push it as he sees
that ball down and then it
bites him but the way he's walking off
and coming out of this game
says it might be a little bit more but
hopefully just a little bit of a strain
and he left that up oh what a catch by
mcmahon
double play six four and athletic
and if he was six three or six two and a
half he would have made this count
correa who flied out to center field his
first time up
correa hooks one down the line plenty of
distance and this ball
is gone home run carlos correa
just bare down the left field line
astros with two solo home runs tonight
and they lead it two to one that was a
bomb
and it got out of here in a hurry we
tucker gets one high in the air to right
field that'll send blackman back he's at
the track and he will
leap and he won't be able to make the
play could tucker get his second triple
in denver he will with a little bit of a
stumble
kyle tucker three career triples two of
them at coors field
he's at third base still nobody out
astros leading two to one and taylor
jones standing in the one two
and jones lines this one in the left
center for a base hit
tucker can walk home taylor jones his
first big league
hit and big league rbi three to one
astros
lefty kyle tucker do up who tripled
against castellani his last time
up tucker goes up for this one and
drives one to left center field that'll
be down for a hit and go all the way to
the wall
curiel will score carlos correa around
third
he's gonna score triple for kyle
tucker and back to back at bats and the
astros lead this game
five to one now it's taylor jones got
his first big league hit in rbi his last
time the one-two
that's grounded sherpley and up the
middle and in the center for a base hit
for taylor jones drives in his second
run of the night as tucker scores
and it's six to one astros how about
taylor jones here is
abraham torah that ball's hit hard
that's a base hit into left field
abraham toro with his first two hits
left-handed this year
tuve going first to third springer
scores astros tack on another it's now
seven to one guriel's the batter
[Music]
this one's driven to right center field
blackman going back in it's gonna
one hop the wall in right center field
hanson the center fielder's got it
altuve scores toro is going to
stay at third base on the ringing double
by guerrielle
it's 10-1 bloomers singing and froger is
back for more
rommer two more ground ball outs this
inning and owings pops one in the air
right field from valdez a single digit
inning
he might want more he's matched his
career high with seven innings pitch
tonight
here is springer pitch on the way and
george
drills this one deep to left center
field and you can
kiss that one goodbye
george springer goes yard for his second
hit of the night and it is 11-1
astros i guarantee you that previous
inning he just had where he threw under
10 pitches is why he's back out there
it's incredible mcmahon play there's a
drive
towards right center field and it's
going to get by reddick and go all the
way to the wall
mcmahon racing around third he will
score
and the rockies get one back it's now
11-2
and tony's going to drop a base hit into
right field and that will score
drew butera and the rockies make it
11-3 seven and two-thirds innings for
from
valdez right now three runs allowed one
earn
tucker
he did kyle tucker deep to right field
give him another two run home run for
kyle tucker a four
hit night home run two triples a single
matches his career high with a four hit
evening but
the most total bases in his young career
in one game
that ball served the other way but
caught by jack mayfield lined up
perfectly for the astros ball game
over the astros win 13-6